peux-tu expliquer un scrutin proportionnel et dire ce que t'en penses
absolument ça me ferait plaisir
en commençant je veux dire deux choses
d'abord généralement
j'appuie pas le scrutin proportionnel
parce que ça crée un niveau d'abstraction de plus
qui éloigne les citoyens des lois
ce qui est contraire aux objectifs démocratiques
et deuxièmement
je reconnais il y a beaucoup de façons différentes
d'avoir des modes de scrutin proportionnels
dont des façons qui répondent à certaines de mes critiques
mon but ici c'est pas
d'expliquer toutes les variantes possibles du mode de scrutin proportionnel
mais d'en expliquer les grands principes et pour ça allons au tableau
on peut représenter l'idéal démocratique par une démocratie directe
ça c’est quand les citoyens choisissent directement les lois
par des référendums par exemple
et les lois contraignent les citoyens
ça veux dire que les citoyens sont redevables envers eux-mêmes
mais dans les sociétés complexes comme la nôtre
on considère généralement que c'est impossible
ou au moins vraiment pas très pratique
on a besoin de trop de lois spécialisées
ça prendrait trop de temps
à tous les citoyens pour s'informer pour voter sur chaque loi
alors on s'organise en démocratie représentative
dans une démocratie représentative les citoyens choisissent des élus
c'est les élus qui font les lois
mais les élus sont directement redevables envers les citoyens
ça fait en sorte que indirectement
les citoyens restent redevables envers eux-mêmes pour leurs lois
sous un scrutin proportionnel
les citoyens choisissent à la place des partis politiques
et c'est les partis politiques qui
eux nomment les élus qui font les lois
ça fait en sorte que les élus sont plus redevables directement aux citoyens
mais sont maintenant redevables aux partis politiques
certains vont me dire que c'est pas grave
parce que les partis politiques sont redevables aux citoyens
alors indirectement le lien est maintenu
mais c'est pas le cas
en pratique les partis politiques sont redevables aux membres du parti
et pas aux citoyens en général
et ça ça fait en sorte que maintenant
un interface ou une abstraction de plus entre les citoyens
et les lois qui les contraignent et la capacité
pour les citoyens d'être redevable envers eux-mêmes
on s'éloigne de l'idéal démocratique
bien-sûr il y a beaucoup de façons de faire un scrutin proportionnel
et il y en a qui viennent mitiger ce problème là
mais il y en a aucun qui l'efface au complet
c'est pour ça que généralement j'appuie pas le scrutin proportionnel
je préfère beaucoup le scrutin préférentiel
qui maintient le lien de redevabilité directe entre les élus et les citoyens
jeux vidéo là-dessus si ça vous intéresse